جاء اعلان رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
والقائد العام للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهاني
بتكوين القوه تدخل سريع تحت ابره القائد
عام للجيش يؤكد الفجوه والاحتدال لنستمر
على التكنولوجيا الحديثه المستخدمه الان
في العمليات اللي هو الطيران مسير نحن
نفتكر انه الان اصبحنا قادرين اننا نمتلك
ناصيه هذه التقنيه الان لدينا امكانيه
جيده من الطيران المسير اذا كان الاستطلاع
او اذا كان للقتال فنحن بنفتكر انه دي
خطوه مهمه ودي
النموذج للوحده نحن في وحدات السلاح
الاستراتيجي
رساله بدات موجهه لقوات الدعم السريع
بقياده حمته كون الجيش يمتلك بالفعل اخر
طراز من المسيرات التركيه في حين فشلت
قوات الدعم السريع في اقتنائها لتعذر
الاتراك عن بيعها الا عبر وزاره الدفاع
السودانيه القوه الضاربه التي تحدث عنها
البرهان ليست جديده واعاده الاعلان عنها
الان
وتبعيتها للقائد العام تاتيان في اطار حسم
دمج قوات الدعم السريع ككتله واحده في
الجيش هذه الخطوه تمثل انتصارا لتيار
الصقور وتجاوزا لمحطه الاختلاف في
التقديرات العسكريه في البرهان الذي كان
يفضل التهدئه في ملف التعامل مع الدعم
السريع اتوافق اخيرا مع التيار الاخر الذي
يقوده الفريق شمس الدين كباشي الاستغلالي
عامل الوقت مقابل نمو الدعم السريع وتيره
قويه ومتسارعه
قصص الخلاف على الدعم السريع تعود الى
تكوينه في 2014 رفض الجيش وقتها الحاق هذه
القوه الجديده به لنواتها المكونا من
قبليات محدده اختار بالتالي الرئيس
السوداني السابق عمر البشير ان يلحق
القوات قوات الدعم السريع بالجهاز الامن
والاستخبارات قبل ان تشتغل بشكل كبير
وتصبح في 2017 قوات انفصاليه منفصله
وامرتها بيد رئيس الجمهوريه تجدد الخلاف
بعد التظاهرات التي دعت للاطاحه بالبشير
في ديسمبر 2018 خاصه بعد الرفض حميتي قائد
الدعم السريع المشاركه في قمع هذه
التظاهرات وبلغ الخلاف ذروته بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير في ابريل 2019 ورفض وقتها الفريق
حمرتي العمل مع رئيس المجلس العسكري
الجديد الفريق عوض بن عوف معجله بانسحاب
الاخير من المشهد
الشوط الثاني من الحكومه الانتقاليه عجل
بالتصاعد الخلافات مع المكون المكون
العسكري في المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
سيضم نحو 14 شخصا وممثلا واحدا فقط للدعم
السريع ما يعتبره حمضتي خطوه تمثل احتواءا
ناعما لقواته وهو الذي شرع في تكوين
التحالفا يعتمد على اعيان القبائل يلتحم
في نهايه المطاف مع تحالف اخر من القوى
المدنيه
الوضعيه الهامه للقوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع هم على الجيشين متوازيه
ما في اذا تحولت المعركه لمعركه عسكريه
بمؤسسات عسكريه وانتصر فيها عسكري قتلت
المدنيه الى الابد
[موسيقى]